and this is how you'll get Blake out of  the game he just found out yep everybody  here should get on their feet after a  standing ovation and they are and they  are look at this on one leg he's got a  flat tire in his he is appreciated by  what he has done  this is the Detroit mentality there's a  guy sitting to my right bin Wallace  helped them win a championship  the F that type of mentality plays  little plays and I'm sure Ben can  appreciate what he has seen and Blake  these last two ballgames they might not  have translated two wins but in the big  picture  the Detroit faithful here they'll look  back on what he has done these last two  ball games to play in these games and  give everything that he possibly could  give I mean that's kudos to that man  right there